this robot wants to put a stamp on a
package but when it gets there it's too
small
never fear it has a trick up its servos
it takes itself apart and reassembles
into a new shape now it can reach this
is called a modular robot it's key skill
adapting it isn't a first modular robot
but unlike many of its counterparts this
one is able to sense its environment
analyze the challenges it faces and
choose a new configuration to solve them
all on its own
clever lot it's made up of individual
units which researchers call s'mores
they connect each other
magnetically the s'mores units all work
together to achieve tasks and they also
carry around their own brain this tall
black module full of sensors and
processes here the robots been tasked
with picking up a pink object and
putting it in a drop-off zone data from
its camera gradually builds up a digital
map of where it is as it drives and
clocks its targets it locates the pink
object but it won't fit in the narrow
gap so it accesses a library of
different behaviors and configurations
in its memory to find a solution in this
case it reconfigures into a new shape
called the proboscis now it can reach
the object and pull it up but it needs
to take it to the drop-off zone and that
proboscis is long and awkward so it
reconfigures back into the car formation
to complete its task
the robot can also climb stairs in the
snake formation or zip around flat
ground in the Scorpion formation okay
perhaps zip is a bit much right now the
robots pretty slow and sometimes it
needs a bit of help but the researchers
say that this system lays the groundwork
for future BOTS which could reorganize
themselves to suit a whole host of
surroundings robots which they hope one
day could help in search and rescue
missions
what adaptable little machines